we do have new information on a stabbing
attack at a Hanukkah celebration in
Muncie New York police say 37 year old
Grafton Thomas wounded five people
inside a rabbis home
New York's governor called it domestic
terrorism and the attack is part of a
national rise in anti-semitic incidents
and harassment Tom Hansen is in Muncie
less than 30 miles north of New York
City Tom what's the latest on the
victims good morning well an elderly man
was seriously hurt in the stabbing he's
still in critical condition as far as we
know four others were also injured
including the son of a rabbi but as
we've heard time and time again from
this religious community they are
refusing to be silenced by the violence
that happened here members of the Jewish
community rallied in Brooklyn Sunday
night hours after dozens gathered in the
afternoon outside rabbi hyman Berg's
home we're not gonna cower in the face
of hate the knife ambush happened
Saturday around 10:00 p.m. at the home
where more than 100 Orthodox Jews were
gathered to celebrate Hanukkah witnesses
say a man stormed in with a weapon and
his face covered walking around and
wielding a knife Joseph block says he
chased down the attacker and through
this table at him I thought this came
everybody away everybody away five
people were stabbed the suspect
allegedly fled in a car but not before
Gluck says he got the suspects license
plate number Grafton Thomas was
apprehended by police a couple hours
later in New York City
shortly after the attack rabbi Rotenberg
continued the event in a nearby
synagogue a motive for Thomas's alleged
violence is not yet known but it comes
amid a rise in anti-semitic attacks and
incidents earlier this month
two shooters opened fire on a Jewish
owned grocery store in New Jersey four
people including a police detective were
killed the FBI is investigating it as
domestic terrorism we see anger we see
hatred exploded New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo says there's been around 13
anti-jewish incidents in the last few
weeks it is a an American cancer in the
body politic now Thomas's public
defender entered a not guilty plea for
him his family also released a statement
overnight saying that he has a long
history of mental illness and
hospitalizations but no known history of
anti-semitism
he's expected in court on Friday Tom
thank you
you